all tied as gobert goes one of two  murray dropped to a knee here he comes  again down the paint  dropping a dime and grant blocked by  gobert  two to shoot murray shoots and he buries  it  trying to live to see another day murray  jokic has broken up by conley murray  off another broken play  and murray says let's slow things down  and what a match up here  between these two superstars murray  a step back long two got it  mitchell is bumped  murray just taken donovan mitchell  murray's coming for more  50 in game four 40 tonight  murray again the mesmerizing  talent of jamal murray nine nine-point  denver lead  so neil and said we'll do the same thing  that's good defense by royce o'neill